[Music]
the following
is a presentation of the st louis chess
club
the spring 2021 season of the st louis
corporate chess league
in an unusual way as mike cummer
attempts to both
host and play for one of the teams
and now your host mike cummer welcome to
the corporate chess league
this is virtual event number three
and ben simon was incorrect i will not
be playing for the merits
corporation this time around i didn't go
4-0 last time and they put me on the
bench so uh
better luck next time kid so hopefully
i'll get another chance to play it was a
real pleasure but i'm just gonna be
focusing on the hosting
tonight and i am international
arbiter michael j comma all right
so let's see some standings here
so winning it all
both both uh both times around
is edward jones with one seven seven and
a half
points wwt coming in
second place with 103 and a half
merits the team i got to play for
is currently in third with 82 points
doherty has 78. now you notice
there's four names on that side that's
the side you want to be on
because we're all accumulating these
grand prix points
to make it into the final four
which will be the sixth event of the
spring league
but right behind is express scripts with
71
the reigning champion of the corporate
chess league enterprise 62 and a half
ascension 48 points bear
with 36 and a half arko in their
debut year 29
and not participating tonight as umb
with
four points so that is the standings
how do you get the points that's a great
question
so this is how you do it so ev
for every for every game victory
you will get a point and for every
draw your team will receive a half point
but if you win your match
that is when you get 20 bonus points
or you know if you draw your match
you'll get
10. and we will be playing back to back
rounds
this evening so you play one with each
color
against your opposing board so
we will play two matches tonight and
kicking
it off tonight is round one which should
be
almost underway we got some matches we
got
arco against ascension edward jones
versus bear
edward jones actually has uh
as a forfeit loss all ready to start
the day so bear is up to nothing right
now
i got my scoreboard out so i'll be
following along
enterprise will be playing wwt that will
be a good match
doherty holding on with that fourth
position
we'll be playing the team right behind
them express scripts so we'll have to
take it
take a look at that one and then we have
of course we have some
extra matches as well so yeah you see
express script so if express scripts
would
beat doherty they would definitely
get over into the final four side and
that's the side
you want to be on all right let's see if
some of these players have logged in
and we'll start following some games
all right i am following a couple games
uh it looks like possibly we have not
started the uh the corporate chess
league
okay now now it's it's it's
it's about to start here uh
special thanks to our our chief
tournament director
nicholas risco he he develops this uh
awesome uh master sheet where uh
where he's got all the games all the
different game logs and you can just
press the challenge button
and we're underway so we have
moneyballin
with with the champs enterprise against
wade s with wwt
all right wade s i've known wade since
a long time since since the old
quest wood chess club days at white
cliff park so
he's been a while all right so let's see
what is going
on so far we do have a an eval
bar it says moneyballing is off to a
a one point lead already so wade playing
uh
a thinker a6 preparing a c5
interesting i'll see if we can find a
another game tonight
let's follow uh kamuni
all right all right so we do have some
games here
and we have uh cool hand
luke 517 with arko he has actually won a
game
so he got some uh contributing points
for his uh
team and he's playing kyqz
who won the uh he won the
best prize
uh last month with ascension well i
shouldn't say last month i should say
well i should say last month it was two
weeks ago
we'll play uh these every two weeks
on uh on a thursday he he defeated uh
uh gary mendel from merits gary mendel
actually did have his uh
his uh gm lesson with uh rgm
in residence sabina foy the uh
the us women's championship from a
couple years back so okay so
congratulations to sabina
and and gary he's like where do i sign
up for more
he had so so much fun so unfortunate
gary wouldn't that be here today
oh bishop takes
and now he just keeps taking and
and yeah this is going to be a really
tough game for uh
cool hand luke to come back so let's go
to uh
let's go
there's rhett he's playing for
for doherty so this is the this is the
big
match of the night doherty against
express scripts
they're both fighting for that fourth
spot of course there's
even if even if they would lose uh
tonight it's not a make it
or break it game but it will go a long
way to determining
who will ultimately end up in the final
four heck
they both might make the final four they
both might uh
might not merits i should note only
brought
two players tonight so they are not
eligible
for their 20-point bonus so the most
they could actually
get tonight is 16
points so that's not too bad
still worth uh because they're currently
in the third position
i'm going to make a bold prediction that
merits will be
out of the final four when this
night is through but you never know they
they are bringing their two
top players so
all right what is going on they have
communi
with express scripts they're saying he's
leading by
two points right now do i believe it but
but the computer big board only has him
plus one so now
they're both like plus one he's a
they're both up that pawn right now
interesting
once again the time control for tonight
is game
10 no delay no increment so
we'll see a lot of good
games ultimately be decided by time
pressure so
and in a team event you do want to play
all the way to the end because every
point counts
gary mendel with uh he's actually the
ceo
for uh color art he didn't get to play
for merits though
but and he he he played to the bitter
end and got the uh
got the stalemate and and it was a it
was a
match clinching draw as well so
merits was able to secure the 20 points
with that drill
with the stalemate so play it to the
bitter end
all right let's check out the the game
money bowling
against wade's moneyballin
claims to have an advantage by the
computer bar
but if you count the pieces they both
have one two
three four five six
six they both have the same amount of
pawns
where is this attack going so
wait wait might want to play oh bishop
d7 just as i was recommending and now we
can either
now we can go back here and have him be
a a defensive piece yeah
yeah yeah i really like that plan for
wade
i don't know what king f2 is about
i really don't know i mean i would have
had dreams of maybe playing rook to e1
oh you did not want to take that pawn
because now
queen takes yeah i know i am giving up
my bishop here
but i think i'll have mate in two
because after queen takes
bishop i'll give him a big queen check
your only legal move is king there and
then rook to h1
maybe that's why i wanted to play uh now
it's all making sense why uh
why moneyball and moneyballin had a huge
game
in the uh in the in the final four
in the championship uh
in round two against edward jones
so moneyballin can play that's for sure
and john boyer that
the superstar the board one of uh
of enterprise he of course got the
the armageddon victory over
vishal with .3 seconds but he's really
been training up
his team so that's that's good
now it's just who's going to get
checkmated first
the the computer really thinks wade's
going to do it if he if he plays his
cards right
even though he does have this mate into
threat all right then well queen to
their
queen queen of g6 check followed by rook
to h1 checkmate
who's gonna get mated first
very exciting right now this would not
be checkmate because
the queen would go back to g7
and and block it
but if he if he gets tricky and gets it
off that line
it's going to be in a world of heart
that's for sure
let's check out the old uh youtube uh
stream see if who's watching
edward jones tonight you know how they
always seem to be the favorite they are
in first place right now by an
astounding uh
74 points after just two matches
but they are without their board one the
shawl
and they're also without their captain
and the founder of the corporate chest
leave
league alex carford
because he is on leave
so congratulations to alex
all right let's check out good old
youtube see what they're saying
see if they got oh follow my game or
you know or check out yeah because we
will be giving out a brilliancy prize so
you know if at the end of the night
which is a well you can ask ryan chester
what
what it is but it's usually a free gm
lesson which is
awesome and
they're held uh via skype though just
just so everybody knows
oh he finally got the the bishop
with check so if he didn't have the
bishop with check
it would have been a detrimental
so i bet wade's going to play this check
see if i can be the the top guesser
tonight
yeah i think it's just gonna be a draw
by threefold repetition
but you never know you never know all
right let's check out
good old youtube
last time we were both on youtube
and twitch but not tonight it doesn't
seem
that is correct uh
great producer ben simon confirmed that
we are exclusively on youtube tonight we
got 23
players watching men over 45.
day and night i bet you do that
never really empty and that enlarged
there was an advertisement on uh youtube
we got it going on and uh let's see
what's going on
so we got rook h1 we got a big
check and is this this gonna
be a draw it looks like they've got wade
with the big win
here coming up let's take a quick
commercial break
what do you say ben simon
we'll be right back we'll be right back
everybody
i wins i'm the dead man for the week
fighting spirit
and just refusing to give up are the
skills that are going to
always help you succeed in chess me
creating my own legacy with the name
gable
has a different sake to it granbaster is
the highest title you can get in chess
it's the badasses of the game you sit at
the top
and everybody else tries to come and
knock us off
it is my time to win
the st louis chess club is pleased to
announce the expansion of our
world-class chess facility
the 20 000 square foot expansion and
upgraded facility will feature new
ground-level classrooms supporting
players of all ages
as well as expanded tournament and
community gathering spaces
with state-of-the-art technology
accessibility upgrades including a new
three-story elevator
will provide access for all participants
and allow
even greater community engagement in the
great game of chess
as a proud resident of the central west
end neighborhood for over a decade
our hope is to build upon our investment
into the community
and solidify st louis as america's chess
capital and preeminent global
destination
for lovers of the sport we look forward
to seeing you in our new space in 2021
when we will host the 2021 u.s chess
championships
2021 u.s juniors and senior
championships
the same field cup st louis rapid and
blitz and more
[Music]
well i'm alex kirford i'm the founder of
the corporate chess league
financial advisor and captain of team
edward jones
so the whole concept of the corporate
chess league
was an opportunity to bring together
companies
individuals in a way that could be
competitive
it could be fun and be able to
better engage with some of your
colleagues and so prior to
the pandemic and covet 19 we were able
to gather here in the chess club
meet face to face and have games on a
quarterly basis
it was a lot of fun had a high level of
engagement and people beginning
to be attracted to that edward jones has
been thrilled
to be to help found but also to
participate in the corporate chess
league
and this year actually it's been a
little bit of a change now that we've
gone virtual
our audience has grown we absolutely
love the corporate chess league i can
tell you
my teammates and i we feel like we're
truly a team and we practice
we have regular practices and we take it
seriously it
has really expanded and the engagement
to want to play
even more has happened during this time
so we took
quarterly meetings to now being able to
put on the corporate chess league
once a month here at edward jones we
actually have
people all over north america about 50
000 close to
associates all over north america i have
a really good friend in the phoenix area
who's passionate about chess
it's hard for him to fly out just to
play into a tournament so now that it's
been virtual
he's been participating on the team as
well so in order to capture the essence
of the purpose of the corporate chess
league
we've been able to provide an experience
where
prior to the competition of chess
actually begins
people are able to come into
welcome back to the corporate chess
league
virtual event number three i am your
host
international arbiter my comma i am the
host in
analysis tonight and we do have a score
we got a communi with express scripts
won his first game against doherty
so and and express scripts trying to get
that fourth spot tonight they are just
seven points currently
well six points now behind doherty
they were they they had 71 grand prix
points going in express scripts did and
dougherty had
78 so if you do simple math express
scripts now has 72 points so they're
they're catching up and who whoever wins
this this big match
gets 20 bonus points it's a very
exciting stuff
all right and let's see and and there
you have it kamuni
he got the sweep with the queen to f7
checkmate
you saw it here first so so now it's
78.73
but for for the match it uh express
scripts is up 2-0
oh like i want to see the old uh so wade
ended up winning that
game against moneyball and that that is
definitely
in the in the hunt for the uh for the
brilliancy prize i want to see how that
one uh
how that one ended up
if i can find the game
games
check out some games current games
well well you're just going to have to
uh
oh here we go
we'll go back to the live chest you're
just going to have to trust me that
wade ended up getting them and uh
and we'll we'll we'll we'll definitely
take a look at that game
uh tonight the the brilliant conclusion
but moneyball once is moneyballing once
his revenge it looks like the computer
has moneyballing up by a four and a half
points let's see what's going on
why does he like moneyballin's position
so much
i guess he's got open lines to his uh
king here
the the b file but is it really worth
that much
because if you look well he's got i
guess he's got a two
pawn advantage currently
but wade might be able to take this pawn
back but i don't think he he might not
even want to
or else
or else you know rook takes g4 looks
looks pretty pretty pretty good
oh but he did all right well here it
comes
now you see it get it if if moneyball
and plays this they'll have almost a
nine point advantage
and i i can't imagine that moneyballing
would not
oh playing
doubling up the pawns i mean that this
pawn is in a pin because if it moves
rick is going to take the queen so
huh but he decides he's going to double
up on the h
file
hmm inspiring play by moneyballin
all right so now wade
well he's making a an escape square for
his king okay so now he takes the
takes the g pawn so now where is this
queen gonna go
anywhere
probably the g4 does he have any kind of
escape i mean he could try desperate
things like
bishop takes uh you no you can't even
try because
this bishop is in a pin so yeah he had
to take there
so after night takes now we have a
discovery on the
bishop takes pawn so now uh
the queen is under attack but we have a
really nice spot
for the queen
right
oh and that's what moneyballing does
so he's threatening a big check
or check or check well that's not yep
he needs to get his bishop back or else
there's a very famous uh bobby fischer
moment
in the world championship where
they just block it in oh but he can't
really block it in right now
because bishop takes
but then he's just going to get
checkmated
so he'll put oh no
bishop takes f2 and the tide has
turned
yeah yeah they always say bishops can
move backwards i don't know why
everybody needs
to to get that pounded in their head
but
my moneyball is going to keep fighting
so
so this is going to be a huge two points
for uh
for wade wade will be able to hold on to
win this
i i it's uh but
well that was uh
i mean that's why you never give up in
these events i mean
everything can happen it can all just
one one false move
and uh game over possibly a mouse slip
i don't know
let's see if our brilliant uh tournament
director nicholas risco is updating any
scores say oh he is
he's updating a lot of scores
it looks like currently arco
and ascension are at two
two edward jones
king taker one three two four
stepping in for v shawl on board one he
went two-and-oh
he's playing bears board one tonight
but edward jones unfortunately had uh
a couple people uh forfeit
so that gave bear uh four points
and they added another one
with eagle eye so now they have five and
it looks like
five
five five right now so that one's coming
down to the wire
as we see
this one uh wade really keeping his team
alive here
he's going to have a assuming he holds
on they'll have three points
and uh enterprise the reigning champions
will have five
and then rounding out is that big game
tonight
for uh fourth place doherty against
express scripts oh again we're getting
uh we're getting some live
live updates right now express scripts
has six
to one right now
some exciting times at the corporate
chess league
big check so so two rooks against one
rook
it's it's it's kind of embarrassing
i've seen this this drawn by uh
by two you know c-class players
uh the guy with uh two i guess that was
nick risco was he playing uh one of the
sacas philly brothers
who we got a call from a mid-show last
time
so if they want to call in and reminisce
about
how hard it is to checkmate with two
works against one
feel free
yeah this is this and i was saying i was
guaranteeing a win
but now i i know it says i know it says
on there
plus 55 points but this is harder than
it looks
but i think wade has a very good idea
that
he needs his king over there to help out
oh very exciting so we're going to go to
the youtube chat
maybe uh club manager and development
manager
uh ryan chester has updated the uh the
prize
for this time around
yeah so once this pandemic is all uh
finished with uh the
the velvet manager said uh
you get free lunch with ryan and mike
at the kingside diner now that really
might actually
uh sway
uh who i want to give the brilliancy
prize to now
because i think i know who the who the
favorite is now
so oh there's gonna be checkmate good
job uh
way two-and-oh he got the complicated
checkmate
and he won his first one in grand
fashion
now actually me and way go way back to
you know
the 90s in the crestwood day so i won't
mind
maybe reminiscing with wade but but
we'll we'll see we'll see how
how
see how it goes there's still a whole
other round so that's that's a lot of
games that are going to be played in
round
number two we're probably just wrapping
up with this
round i would imagine
so maybe we can take a quick look at uh
i'll try one more time to find his his
uh his game one
i'm so close
well why don't we take a quick oh i
think i
found it okay all right here we go
all right yeah and as a platinum member
of
chess.com you get this really cool
feature where you get to see
everybody's uh percentages and
how well you did uh yeah if you can uh
play in the high 90s you're doing
something right
and uh it was a back and forth game
where both players
had chances so this is game one of that
uh
of their match
wade had the black pieces
against moneyballin the computer really
did not
like how uh how wade started but
i wouldn't put too much stock in the
with the what the computer thinks about
the opening sometimes
or maybe i put a lot of it in i don't
know it just depends
because our uh grandmaster ben feingold
because he has all the openings
memorized obviously he doesn't even turn
on the chess engine uh you know until
like move seven or eight
unless there's something really uh
crazy going on
oh they did not well yeah i never
like trading my uh fianchetto
bishop in less and less
but the only reason why wade can get
get away with it in this type of
position is notice
that white does not have you know
a you know a bishop that can
they can challenge so so he's like well
if you don't have
a bishop you know that's fine
but we'll see the craziness
oh they don't like queen to h6 that was
the one i
predicted and i that was my one my one
for one
let's see what see what the they want
to be played
they just want him to play check huh and
just trade off the queens
now wait i took a pawn
i'm taken upon so now they love queen to
d4
check which is what wade played
rook a to e8 check his best
rick after e8 is also fine
rick the e2 check is a mistake it looks
it looks good
work to h1
threatening mate in two is just a little
too ambitious i guess
there goes the queen
and wade sees the mate in two so
congratulations
if you think you can top that game and i
like you
uh you can uh submit your game on the
youtube chat and maybe maybe i'll check
it out if we have the time
all right you wanna you wanna take a
little break and we'll be
back with the uh round two results
all right back in a moment
i'm the dead man for the week fighting
spirit and just refusing to give up
are the skills that are going to always
help you succeed in chess me create my
own legacy with the name gable
has a different sake to it granbaster is
the highest title you can get in chess
it's the badasses of the game you sit at
the top
and everybody else tries to come and
knock us off
it is my time to win
the st louis chess club is pleased to
announce the expansion of our
world-class chess facility
the 20 000 square foot expansion and
upgraded facility
will feature new ground-level classrooms
supporting players of all ages
as well as expanded tournament and
community gathering spaces with
state-of-the-art technology
accessibility upgrades including a new
three-story elevator
will provide access for all participants
and allow
even greater community engagement in the
great game of chess
as a proud resident of the central west
end neighborhood for over a decade
our hope is to build upon our investment
into the community
and solidify st louis as america's chess
capital and preeminent global
destination
for lovers of the sport we look forward
to seeing you in our new space in 2021
when we will host the 2021 u.s chess
championships
2021 u.s juniors and senior
championships
the same field cup st louis rapid and
blitz and more
well i'm alex kirford i'm the founder of
the corporate chess league financial
advisor and
captain of team edward jones so the
whole concept
of the corporate chess league was an
opportunity to bring together
companies individuals in a way that
could be competitive
it could be fun and be able to
better engage with some of your
colleagues and so prior to
the pandemic and covet 19 we were able
to gather here in the chess club
meet face to face and have games on a
quarterly basis
it was a lot of fun had a high level of
engagement and people beginning
to be attracted to that edward jones has
been thrilled
to be to help found but also to
participate in the corporate chess
league
and this year actually it's been a
little bit of a change now that we've
gone virtual
our audience has grown we absolutely
love the corporate chess league i can
tell you
my teammates and i we feel like we're
truly a team and we practice
we have regular practices and we take it
seriously it
has really expanded and the engagement
to want to play
even more has happened during this time
so we took
quarterly meetings to now being able to
put on the corporate chess league
once a month here at edward jones we
actually have
people all over north america about 50
000 close to
associates all over north america i have
a really good friend in the phoenix area
who's passionate about chess
it's hard for him to fly out just to
play into a tournament so now that it's
been virtual
he's been participating on the team as
well so in order to capture the essence
of the purpose of the corporate chess
league
we've been able to provide an experience
where
prior to the competition of chess
actually begins
people are able to come into our google
hangouts page
and be able to see and interact with
each other
in a virtual way and then partnering
with chess.com we're able to provide
the the actual tournament and and how
the competition begins
and the corporate chess league allows us
as a team a to bond
and we're doing really well as a team
i'm happy to say and b it allows us to
kind of uh you know
uh rib each other a little bit and and
it is a little friendly banter which we
love
and all during that time the st louis
chess club is hosting
a youtube channel that has commentary
from
guest speakers grand masters
international masters
commentating on how the games are
actually going
that makes for a lot of fun for people
to be able to
see how their friends how their
colleagues are doing
during a game by having a professional
be able to speak about
the position and and have fun that way
too
i think during this time it is hard
to have motivation sometimes we can get
down on things having
an outlet where competition can still be
involved in your life having an outlet
where you can still have
networking with your colleagues has
really been
a key part of the success of the
corporate chess league
it has been really fun to be able to not
only get to know the people in my own
firm better and share that that similar
passion
but also get to know people from several
different
firms here in in the st louis area
we've continued to have interest in the
corporate chess league both here in the
st
louis area and beyond we're looking
forward to a great season
in 2021 if you or your company
is interested in being a part of the
corporate chess league
you can go to www
www.stlouischestclub.org
and get more information we'd love to
have you be a part of the competition
[Music]
welcome back to the corporate chess
league virtual event
number three they're all trying to get
in
to the final four that will be the sixth
and final event of the spring league and
then we'll have
the fall league so you got
two chances to get your corporation's
name
on the board and if you think this is
fun event
get your team and get your lineup and uh
and register on our st louis
chess club website for the fall league
all right that will debut in september
and wrap up the thursday before
thanksgiving
okay but we are still in the midst of
round one if you can believe it
and it's a huge game
currently arco has
four points they are playing like versus
ascension who has three points so
if if the player from oracle can manage
to
to win or draw arko
we'll get the 20 bonus points
but if ascension if oak avenue can win
his game
then they will split the 20
bonus points and each receive 10. and so
let's see so oak avenue is playing for
ascension
and bolo george is playing
for arco with the black pieces so what
is going on here
so all bolo george needs
is a draw to get to get up to that four
and a half points
so well only one team
probably has a winning advantage right
now and
and that is the past b pawn but it
doesn't look like it's
going anywhere but it doesn't look like
it can really be captured
uh too easily
as well as as you see the bishop will
never be able to uh
to currently attack it
so where oh you just attack
good things happen when you attack
correct maybe i can become the top
guester of this
let's go all the way
oh he wants to attack the knight would
that make sense
um maybe he wants to play like f3
to try and um because this this bishop
is
uh not doing too well
right now but you know if you have
dreams of f3
maybe king back to f1
now you might as well push it again why
not
yep there you go when in doubt
push a side pawn because it's not really
going to mess up your position hopefully
too bad although i did
play a game against gm dennis burroughs
in uh in a game 30 uscf rated game and
if my pawn would have just been on a7
instead of a6
the rumor was i had i would have had a
had a very good game but it was not
meant to be
that was a in one of our staff
tournaments so that was a lot of fun
before the pandemic hit obviously but we
do
still host uh live tournaments here
fridays saturdays and mondays we might
even have a g30 tournament
in a couple weeks on a sunday here
coming up so
be on the lookout for that uh-oh and
there goes the rook
and there goes well well
but you got to play for that draw
because if all you if you just get that
draw
you're still your team will will uh
will still get the win so yeah just play
on
stranger things have happened as we saw
in uh
in the last round with wades and
moneyballing
but well while this one is wrapping up
we you want to go over the rest of the
results from uh
round one ben all right
we we do have uh some some results in
the books it looks like
um edward jones even though they're
playing without their
their board one v shawl
their captain and founder of the uh
corporate chess league
alex corford and two other guys
were paired but didn't show up so when
that happens
you get forfeit losses so bear had
everything going for him they had edward
jones right where they wanted him
but edward jones's team has a
much depth and uh they were able to
still
secure the victory 8-6
and so they'll get the uh their bonus
20. so right now they have 28 points
guess who else has 28 points
enterprise all right yeah who would have
guessed so enterprise has 28 points
they are very top-heavy with uh
with kamikaze knight and chess hulky so
they were they managed to go 4-0 and
basically set the table
and uh they ended up beating wwt
despite wade's best efforts uh
they won eight to four
uh express scripts two four
six eight nine to three
over doherty so they will now
vault into that final four spot from
from fifth to uh to fourth
and you notice that express scripts has
33 points even though they just had
nine points plus the 20
there are some extra matches that also
go on
and they're worth the uh well ultimately
it could be worth two bonus points but a
point for
a win so so they accumulated some points
that way
and it looks like we have a tie
with arco
oh yeah four
four arko and ascension they they
got the tie
yeah he saw that he was gonna get
checkmated in five moves
and so he uh he ended up uh
calling it a day and now we do have some
matches
for round two as they were chomping at
the bit they couldn't wait
they couldn't wait to start round two so
705 isn't uh too late to start
uh the round two so
we'll we try we try to we try to get
this event
done by uh eight o'clock as you know
everybody is uh
very busy in their professional lives in
the corporate chess league
so that's why we have no
no delay no increment game 10. so so
if everybody gets their uh their
challenges in
and then their rematches right away you
know
the round's only going to last you know
40
41 minutes tops so and that's if
everybody's playing to the bitter end
which and sometimes and sometimes
they do so off to round two and then we
got some uh
well let's let's let's do the uh the
official standings
just so everybody sees uh ben simon can
we get
get oh no no not for the season we will
have a big tally at the end
to to let everybody know uh what what
position they're in in the final four
but uh okay so
this is just for tonight's event express
scripts is leading
edward jones who has never lost
one of these regular season events
whether virtual or in a person
they have lost obviously the final four
championship to uh
to john boyer dime boyer
from enterprise they got their name on
the board and they have lost some
pre-season events which
is understandable so they got some work
to do that's what i'm trying to say
express scripts can they hold on
they're they're down by uh so enterprise
is right there with them the reigning
champions
ascension is a one-point lead over
arco with an extra game they won
and then rounding out is bear wwt
merits yeah marissa's uh
two players uh must have gone uh
four and oh so so that's good
that's good because every point
uh adds up and and they're gonna be
trying to cling
to a final four spot and when this is
all said and done
they came in as number three with with
the help of uh
of me and uh gary mendel we we helped
them out uh
the last couple weeks the last couple
events
i should say and then dougherty uh
rounds out with three okay so we got
some
match-ups for uh for this round
hopefully
somewhere round two oh and who would
have guessed
it's express scripts against edward
jones so that's gonna be
the uh the featured match tonight for
sure
can edward jones make a comeback
they're down by five currently oh
and well actually they're down by a lot
more than five
because there might they might have some
forfeit losses coming up
enterprise they're still in the mix
there will be playing arco who is brand
new this year
so the reigning champions against the
brand new team
and then ascension is playing doherty
and wwt versus bear
so it's intense tonight yeah
three teams have a have a great chance
to win it tonight
so i could come down to the wire all
right well on to the games
we will follow uh let's follow uh
edward jones's number one
king taker
one three two four who came up big
in the uh in the first match here
all right so king taker is uh playing
with the white pieces
the computer gives him a three-point
edge even though the scoreboard is
is tied all right
knight attacks the queen so if he took
the knight bye bye queen work takes
so that's uh they're in a pin
it's not really advisable to trade a
queen for a
for a rook and a minor piece so i
don't think he'll be doing that and now
just for fun he's going to give him a
check
that's my guess at least and now we'll
and burdock will he
sacrifice his rook for the night
burdock is playing for express scripts
who is currently leading right now if
you see in the standings 33
and and with their win over dougherty
they're definitely in the final four if
the final four
started right now but there's much work
to do
still here oh he decides
not to play the the very strong check
and
you gotta play it
yeah there you go
can he yeah he can't i don't think he
can withstand the pressure i think he's
gonna take it
oh he doesn't and now he's gonna play
that's it that's that's how fast a game
can go
that's why i mean there's a phrase in
chess
always check that's why you know you
limit
your opponent's options and great things
can happen
so edward jones just keeps
keeps doing well let's see uh
if the tournament director nick
risco the whiz kid he puts together this
whole
uh whole great uh
corporate chess matrix let's see if he
gave
anybody some forfeits
he doesn't say if he uh if he's giving
out four if it's to edward jones or not
ooh queen to b6 i love i love
that move aggressive
even though it's you are it is protected
currently but still put the pressure on
let's go to the youtube comments
oh yeah if you have a game that that you
you that you you
think is a worthy of the win
go for it submit it in the comments
please
wade stallman is the current
uh
is the current uh
if if it was decided right now wade
would definitely uh
it he'd be in it and we get the free
lunch at the new
king diner which is on the
the heart of the central west end at
euclid in maryland where all the action
is
right down the street from the world
chess hall of fame
so
it should be fun they will open in a
very shortly and there will be a
chat oh they are open and they will have
uh their hours are really going to be
cool
they're going to have like chess after
dark
so it'll be uh expanded hours
and uh it should be like uh
like you ever see uh beverly hills 90210
the
peach pit and now they have the peach
pit after dark so who knows
maybe they'll get some bands in there uh
oh i want to talk to a rainbow or
something or how do you talk to a
rainbow or it was it was a good one it
was a good one
i grow up my sideburns i'll be a good
old dylan mckay
yeah this is there's a lot to look
forward to even though it's uh
we're coming out of this and it's 2021
everybody
great time to be alive whether you want
to believe it or not
i believe it thank you
all right so what else we got going on
let's check out
uh kyqz he won the uh
he plays for uh ascension but he won the
uh
the brilliancy prize last month or well
yeah
last month yeah he's doing it looks like
he's doing pretty good he's up a piece
good job uh moneyballing with enterprise
had a tough uh tough go around
enterprise of course is playing arko
here
and uh
he's only plus two on the scoreboard but
the evaluation
has him up by about eight and a half
points so
he just pinned the rook that was
attacking his queen
okay very interesting
his knights up there attacking
let's see if we can get another game
with the edward jones
we're still away in word from our td
if if he did uh punish edward jones with
with basically a 4.4 foot loss because
two of their players did not show up
big check made in one can we see maiden
one
i don't think so yep but
hey i'm not moneyballing so good job
moneyballing you saw the maiden one
and who would've guessed it was a big
check i mean usually uh
the queen is going to be uh giving out
the the checkmates but
i was wondering because the night was so
close if if maybe that
there was a tricky night checkmate but
it was not meant to be and they're
right away playing their rematch
all right let's see if uh
follow paul
frouwen with edward jones
see how he's doing let's check out this
game
so this is still their first game they
both have about four
minutes paul frown playing for edward
jones
against express scripts and as you see
on the big standings
express scripts went into this
match with a five-point lead over edward
jones
edward jones of course short-handed
tonight without their uh
they're bored one and without their uh
captain
as well alex corford the founder of the
corporate chess league
so there but they're making the most of
it they're making the most of it
so good for them
and in this game it's giving the
the gentleman from express scripts
a very narrow lead on the evaluation bar
this is the evaluation bar but
in in reality it's uh it's all tied up
so he attacks the rook
he's got to go all the way back to h2
notice if he stopped a little short
bishop would take with
check so that's the only place to be
oh f6 whenever you
whenever you're tempted to play f6 you
always want to look for a better move
i even taught ben feingold that never
play f6
although he would probably say it was
all him
but who knows
ben feingold is of course with the chess
club and scholastic center
of atlanta i wonder if he's since
changed the name to uh
atlanta chess club just like we switched
it up so
you never know you never know good for
ben
ooh okay kyqz
with ascension won his game
oak avenue also with ascension
won his first game they were playing
against doherty
doherty had a final four spot coming
into
tonight but it looks just like
possibly merits that we could have two
brand new additions into the final four
because if you look at the at the at the
grand
standings going into the round edward
jones had 177 and a half
there they are wwt trailing mightily
with with 103 and a half merits with 82
and authority was 78.
so express scripts they're definitely
going to get a spot
unless they have an epic collapse
against edward jones so
and then who knows enterprise with their
if they can if they can
defeat arko uh they they could
they could also be in the final four
when it's all said and done tonight
so should be should be interesting we'll
we'll
we'll tabulate all the all the scores up
before we uh get off
off the air tonight so we'll let
everybody know
what's going on and also you can follow
the corporate chess league on our st
louis
chess club website can i go to that
ben simon st louis chessclub.org you
check that out
and then join and give we
no donation right that's what they said
no donation
too small we we put it to great use too
so if you click on corporate chess
league down here
uh we will have the pairings and the
standings
and then you it's it's unfortunately too
late to
to register for the spring league but
but
the fall league it's coming up coming up
sooner than you thinks memorial day will
be here
in may then then labor day
and then we'll wrap it all all up before
thanksgiving
shout out to the st louis cardinals
opening day at busch stadium today
our new our new guy uh nolan had a
huge home run and hopefully we held on
to win
i really hope so and there's like
13 000 people in the stands so that's
that's good three to one we win yeah
all right but but we got a lot of
business
uh to attend to right now
we've got uh
we've got paul with edward jones
it's oh he's down by a point it they say
on the scoreboard but but they kind of
like his position
because
now they got made in four let's see if
you can see it there's one check
oh is that just going to be so after
how okay so if you play king f7
how can we get the check mate
because that's what he's going for
this is tough to see especially if
you're 1308
especially if you're a set well 1700 in
reality
or maybe i should be a 1600 uh yeah i
did not want to play
check because you can just take
wow does any oh no now it's over
i got i got i well i'm like in that one
game
the moneyballing game i was able to see
this made in one
especially when the computer's telling
me hey you got made in one
oh man i wonder i wonder how he would
have had to
uh to have done that maybe if we have
time
tonight we can look at that game
i'm gonna take a note of that the pull
frown game
mate in three
so all right let's see uh
see what else is going on here we've got
a game
we got a game who who is the oh this got
to be the doherty
uh the doherty guy
ascension was doing a very well in their
uh
in their game yeah they're currently up
four to nothing
on doherty
let's go to this uh k way cuz he's got
made in one
a queen to be b1 checkmate all the way
uh they didn't let him put it on the
board he didn't give him the
satisfaction
so kyqz
with ascension gets another win
all right oh looks like this
is the game to watch paul
frown with edward jones against a warner
621
with express scripts seems like a lot of
the other games are
already getting getting done with
enterprise
the reigning champion is currently up
4 to nothing against arko
so all they would need is a half
point
am i saying that right yes yes so if you
get four and a half points here
you get the bonus 20. so right it's
going to be
very close to see uh
well it's going to be very close to see
who won one straight out
wins tonight's match and to see how the
the final four shakes out because they
were it after uh
after tonight there will just be two
events left
to see who makes it to the final four
to wrap up the spring league
bear in a close one against uh
wwt oh but
uh our td uh nick risco just added
another point
to uh to bear so bear
is now doubling them four to two
oh make it six
to two bear
edward jones oh so
ward from our td nick risco
they did award express scripts
four points right off the bat for
forfeit victories
but i mean we have to i i was i was
making
helping nick uh well nick bailed me out
but i
i was making that sheet earlier today in
case uh
nick wasn't able to and it's very
complicated
to get these pairings so if you say
you're going to play
and we've made the sheet unfortunately
we cannot go back
it's forfeit loss so
right now but edward jones they are
resistant and they have tied it up
for four now
so and it's will be one two three four
five
six seven so first one to seven and a
half points
will get to match victory
possibly win this event
and most importantly get that 20 extra
points
wow so this this is a this is
every game counts so wow so all that all
all express scripts really needed was
three and a half points to secure the
victory over edward jones
but edward jones maintaining they're not
going to give them
anything it looks like so
this is going to be good and right now
in this game
uh paul frowan with edward jones against
express scripts
it looks like the uh
[Music]
the scoreboard has it
just equal they have the same amount of
material but
but the computer it's got a mind of its
own saying no
black has the advantage by a pawn let's
actually go back to that last game
and see how uh see if we can find the
mate
in three oh oh
oh but but they did not like
knight to e4 knight takes
oh because now it's uh well
one it's a discovered attack on the
queen and
it's a pawn fork so once the queen moves
bye bye bishop pawn takes bishop
check so
i'll just be get get a get a free guess
in here
and he should just take back then
we take back with the king watch out
watch out for this check
let's see if he's just going to throw it
in just for fun
even though you're almost helping your
guy out
oh i i i the queen
is under attack just so everybody knows
so he's got to watch out he does throw
in the check
so once once he moves out of the check
oh you did not want to go to d2 because
now the rook
check he you should just trade the
queens and call it a day
because if oh if you try something funny
well you gotta just take because if you
don't you're gonna get checkmated down
here
see if if you move the queen off the
line
you're gonna be in a world of hurt yeah
so queen takes h3 was played
and now you double the rooks excellent
and now
this is almost lights out
i i don't oh oh you gotta play
well i don't even know what you can play
you're i
one you're gonna get checkmated or
you're going to lose the rook nice try
but it doesn't work
yeah yeah so edward jones wins again
let's see if we can find out how uh
how they could have gotten uh the
checkmate
and this this is well we started a
little bit late this
this round we started at 705 so about
25 minutes in where
uh a lot of the games have uh have
wrapped up pretty much i want to see how
how paul frown could have had the uh
the checkmate in the last one
he ultimately got it but
but i couldn't find the checkmate and
neither
could he so
so at the very end here
now they were they say it's like mate in
three right here
it's all over my bishop there put my
bishop there
and then rook chuck is it that easy
all right so this is my guess bishop
here i don't care what you do
bishop there
well it's not going to be made in three
because if i go
backwards well let's just let's check it
out let's check it out
so okay so
so they're like made in three king f7
and then rook d to e8
let's get the right one all right
he's gonna throw in a spike check
and we'll take with the this guy
and then yeah whatever you play
checkmate
good game all right well
we'll take a break and tabulate some
scores
we'll get uh the brilliancy prize winner
free lunch with michael j and ryan
chester at the
new kingside diner at its new location
just a throw away from the chess club
i will be back in a moment
the st louis chess club is pleased to
announce the expansion of our
world-class chess facility
the 20 000 square foot expansion and
upgraded facility
will feature new ground-level classrooms
supporting players of all ages
as well as expanded tournament and
community gathering spaces with
state-of-the-art technology
accessibility upgrades including a new
three-story elevator will provide access
for all participants and allow even
greater community engagement
in the great game of chess as a proud
resident of the central west end
neighborhood for over a decade
our hope is to build upon our investment
into the community
and solidify st louis as america's chess
capital and preeminent global
destination
for lovers of the sport we look forward
to seeing you in our new space in 2021
when we will host the 2021 u.s chess
championships
2021 u.s juniors and senior
championships
the same field cup st louis rapid and
blitz and more
[Music]
well i'm alex kirford i'm the founder of
the corporate chess league
financial advisor and captain of team
edward jones
so the whole concept of the corporate
chess league
was an opportunity to bring together
companies
individuals
hello everybody welcome back we have a
an exciting game to um to finish up the
program edward jones
is uh is playing
his their competitor is dn274
against neil essie from express scripts
and all these points mean
life and death right now express scripts
has
five points to edward jones's
six points first one to seven and a half
points
will probably end up being the grand
champion tonight so
as you see express scripts is currently
leading by one point over enterprise
edward jones not too far
back so
but the winner of the match between
express scripts and edward jones will
give that bonus 20 points
so let's see what's going on
neil is with express chris is up by
five points on the scoreboard as you see
he has a queen
where uh 274 does not
his knight is being attacked right now
so
he's only got one place to hop it to
this bishop needs to well i guess this
bishop's doing a good job defending but
but and then the clock is a factor right
now
three minutes to three minutes they're
under that five minute mark
it's game and 10 no delay no increment
this could be for everything
see what happened in the in the uh
king taker game
yeah there there is a there is a
a game or they're on the top board
between nate and king taker and they
just nick just just updated
king taker on board one for vishal
went 4-0 so that's another point to
edward jones
so now they have six seven points
to express scripts five and
express scripts was granted
four crucial points for the
forfeitures so neil
really needs to come up big for express
scripts if they want
any chance but he did win the first game
and he is
higher ranked than his opponent
and he's got more pieces if andy's got
more time so i'm i like neil's chances
in this one but
in the corporate chess league anything
can happen we've seen
stalemates determine a match
victory so
if i was if i was his opponent i would
just be bearing down and trying to
to get the win however i can and there
you go
you just got four for three
take with check
and this i mean i was saying that that
two rooks against one rook wasn't the
easiest
uh win although wade did very well he
got his king over there and did it uh
look
i mean both both these guys have the
same amount of pawns on the same
side of the board so it's a
it's a tough one if they could somehow
trade
and to get a queen against rook that's
not a very easy
position to win unless you are uh
ben feingold's uh brother he knows how
to win that
in his sleep so and you only have 50
moves to win that
queen against rook you just keep the
king and the rook
together and hopefully you can you can
force a draw
so but i think
ultimately he might lose on time
oh and and uh oh he finally got his rook
in the game
if if if neil doesn't he's got a trade
he's got a trade he cannot let him have
that
if if if if rook d7 is played
lights out oh and he plays it
i mean it it it cost him a pawn but
oh maybe he could just slide it over
that's what i was thinking
but now you play rook here and don't let
him get to that uh
that rank you got to play rook d7 here
it's a must
move
oh they went too far it's over
even i can see the maiden three here
and i have been having trouble doing
them but
but yeah that's that's that's game yeah
so a a big win for neil
and it's keep he's keeping expresses
scripts
hopes alive
so they currently have six points but
edward jones once again wins eight to
six and uh
but will it be enough to catch
enterprise
you never know well
we'll let you know when we come back in
a moment
thank you
chess league financial advisor and
captain of team edward jones
so the whole concept of the corporate
chess league
was an opportunity to bring together
companies
individuals in a way that could be
competitive
it could be fun and be able to
better engage with some of your
colleagues and so prior
to the pandemic and covet 19 we were
able to gather here
in the chess club meet face to face and
have games on a quarterly basis
it was a lot of fun had a high level of
engagement and people beginning to be
attracted to that
edward jones has been thrilled to be to
help found but also to participate in
the corporate chess league
and this year actually it's been a
little bit of a change now that we've
gone virtual
our audience has grown we absolutely
love the corporate chess league i can
tell you
my teammates and i we feel like we're
truly a team and we practice
we have regular practices and we take it
seriously it
has really expanded and the engagement
to want to play even more
has happened during this time so we took
quarterly meetings
to now being able to put on the
corporate chess league
once a month here at edward jones we
actually have
people all over north america about 50
000 close to
associates all over north america i have
a really good friend in the phoenix area
who's passionate about chess
it's hard for him to fly out just to
play into a tournament so now that it's
been virtual
he's been participating on the team
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um i'm the dead man for the week
fighting spirit and just refusing to
give up
are the skills that are going to always
help you succeed in chess me
creating my own legacy with the name
gable has a different sake to it
granbaster is the highest title you can
get in chess
it's the badasses of the game you sit at
the top
and everybody else tries to come and
knock us off
it is my time to win
[Music]
the st louis chess club is pleased to
announce the expansion of our
world-class chess facility
the twenty thousand square foot
expansion and upgraded facility
will feature new ground-level classrooms
supporting players of all ages
as well as expanded tournament and
community gathering spaces
with state-of-the-art technology
accessibility upgrades including a new
three-story elevator
will provide access for all participants
and allow
even greater community engagement in the
great game of chess
as a proud resident of the central west
end neighborhood for over a decade
our hope is to build upon our investment
into the community
and solidify st louis as america's chess
capital and preeminent global
destination
for lovers of the sport we look forward
to seeing you in our new space in 2021
when we will host the 2021 u.s chess
championships
2021 u.s juniors and senior
championships
the same field cup st louis rapid and
blitz and more
well i'm alex kirford i'm the founder of
the corporate chess league financial
advisor and
captain of team edward jones so the
whole concept
of the corporate chess league was an
opportunity to bring together
companies individuals in a way that
could be competitive
it could be fun and be able to
better engage with some of your
colleagues and so prior to
the pandemic in covet 19 we were able to
gather here
in the chess club meet face to face and
have games on a quarterly basis
it was a lot of fun had a high level of
engagement and people beginning
to be attracted to that edward jones has
been thrilled
to be to help found but also to
participate in the corporate chess
league
and this year actually it's been a
little bit of a change now that we've
gone virtual
our audience has grown we absolutely
love the corporate chess league i can
tell you
my teammates and i we feel like we're
truly a team and we practice
we have regular practices and we take it
seriously it
has really expanded and the engagement
to want to play
even more has happened during this time
so we took
quarterly meetings to now being able to
put on the corporate chess league
once a month here at edward jones we
actually have
people all over north america about 50
000 close to
associates all over north america i have
a really good friend in the phoenix area
who's passionate about chess
it's hard for him to fly out just to
play into a tournament so now that it's
been virtual
he's been participating on the team as
well so in order to capture the essence
of the purpose of the corporate chess
league
we've been able to provide an experience
where
prior to the competition of chess
actually begins
people are able to come into our google
hangouts page and be able to see and
interact with each other in a virtual
way
and then partnering with chess.com we're
able to provide
the the actual tournament and and how
the competition begins
and the corporate chess league allows us
as a team a to bond
and we're doing really well as a team
i'm happy to say and b it allows us to
kind of
you know
welcome back to corporate chess league
spring event number three and what a
doozy it was
and for the first time in regular season
history
edward jones will not be winning
an event congratulations to the reigning
champion
of the corporate chess league enterprise
they nearly held on with 58 and a half
points
to edward jones's 56 obviously the
founder of the corporate chess league
was not here tonight neither was their
board one
b shawl so congratulations to captain
john boy your time boyer of
enterprise they got the win tonight
coming in third place ascension
express scripts they were going
toe to toe against edward jones
but they still had a fantastic night
39 and a half points bear
didn't hear much from them today but
they ended up getting 36 points
arko with 14. wwt
is interested we'll have more about wwt
later
they got a dozen points merits
who only brought two players got the
maximum
and got got all eight points was it
enough
to hold on to a final four spot
well we'll wait and see and rounding out
the field doherty
so let's take a look at what the grand
prix
points were coming into the day
obviously the only way to get into that
final four
is to be on the left side of my screen
so i don't know if it's the opposite but
you want to have the more points
you got to get in that final four by
accumulating these points
holding on to this top spot it's they're
still safe
edward jones has 233 and a half points
now there's going to be some new teams
in here
enterprise with their big victory
tonight
is now in the second spot with 121
grand prix points express scripts with
their day
they're also coming over to the uh to
the left side of the screen
and they now have a hundred and ten and
a half points
and it's very close
to see who is in
the final four spot wwt
held on and uh
and they're in they're they're still in
but we'll tell we'll we'll tell you how
many points
wwt has uh later all right but just
just keep in mind they held on and
they're rounding out the field it's very
close
ascension is now in fifth place with 91
merits with uh 90. so they're they're
right there they've still got a chance
and then doherty 85 bear with 72 and a
half so they they almost doubled their
score
and uh then arko has 43 and umb who did
not participate
still still still has their four points
so
that wraps up the night not yet though
where we do have a free lunch to give
away at the gamlin whiskey house
i used to hang out with this uh
gentleman uh
way back in the white cliff park in the
uh 90s
wades and i used to attend uh some of
his uh tournaments in brentwood too
you give out uh huge trophies
and i got my hands on some of that
hardware and guess what
you get to have uh lunch sometime when
we're all
all nice and healthy again at the
kingside diner with myself
and club manager and development manager
ryan chester thank you to uh ben simon
and the td nick risco
and of course ryan lauren and tara meyer
good night everybody
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club